du hast bestimmt ein lieblings
restaurant und vielleicht hast du schon
mal versucht ihm zu erklären warum genau
das restaurant dein lieblings restaurant
ist und vielleicht hast du dabei
festgestellt dass es gar nicht mal so
leicht zu sagen warum essen gut ist ob
es gut ist und naja aus diesem grund
gibt es leute deren job genau das ist
und eine solche person durfte schon mal
auf einem kanal begrüßen carsten henn
den restaurantkritiker aus köln vor dem
wirklich jedes restaurant angst hat
wirklich das festgestellt jeder kennt
jeder angst vor dem jeder sagt oh wenn
der kommt gehen wir uns extra mir aber
legen wir direkt los ich bin zu
maximieren lorenz gefahren aber nicht
ins sterne restaurants sondern ins
wahllokal und habe dort gemeinsam mit
carsten gegessen und er hat mir erklärt
von a bis z wie er als
restaurantkritiker arbeitet es kommt
alles wieder zusammen lehrerin hat sich
an diesem mann ich bin ganz froh dass
wir gemeinsam sitzen und so begann sich
entweder getröstet und heute erklärt du
mir wie du arbeitest das mache ich genau
und jetzt ist das zweite restaurant
eines sternekochs das ist ganz ganz
spannend zu sehen was kommt aus
derselben küche ja wie die wie die
gerichte nebenan im spitzenrestaurant
das heißt die erwartungshaltung ist echt
hoch der muss liefern der das buch muss
hat sich das ganz kleinteilige seien
aber die punkte müssen alle exakt
getroffen seien über laos bislang seien
insofern ich bin ich gespannt aber dass
auch die reihe kriegt ich glaube das ist
also etwas besonderes was selten ist
dass man richtigen restaurant bringt ihr
über die schulter guckt und eine sache
die ich dir erzählen was wir waren ja
wirklich in einigen restaurants in
einigen guten restaurants und in jedem
restaurant hat eine wirklich für
ehrfurcht gewirkt berichtete dass ich
natürlich sagen das ist mir persönlich
wird im nachgang erst bewusst geworden
dass sein name glaube ich hier aus sehen
so aus in der ein oder anderen guten
küche hier im umkreis um so gespannter
bin ich was wir heute alles beibringen
katze ja ja das ist bestens bestellt ja
bestellen erster punkt bestellen und mit
die schwierigste aufgabe für den
restauranttester es geht nämlich darum
mit einer kleinen auswahl von gerichten
das gesamte restaurant das gesamte
portfolio zu testen bewerten zu können
und eine aussage über die gesamte karte
treffen zu können jede facette des
restaurants muss verstanden werden
genauso haben wir auch bestellt ich
gucke immer ist auf die gerichte die
schwierig sind für die küche also wo ich
weiß der geier punkt ist schwieriger zu
treffen oder es ist eine kombination die
leicht abrutschen kann was manchmal hast
du sachen die können dann zu sauer sein
oder zu bitter sein oder wenn leute die
meinen sie müssten mit was arbeiten was
die sich kennen wie schokolade und dann
verhauen die sich immer das heißt ich
gucke was sind die schwierigen gerichte
ja selbst wir nicht bock habe auch was
was einfach ist wenn ich darf das nicht
essen ich muss das nehmen wo der koch
potenziell daran scheitern weil du auch
einfach davon ausgeht denn das klappt
klappt alles andere auch genau es gibt
so einige gerichte wurde weiß wenn die
gut gelegen sein gelingt alles märchen
zum beispiel wenn du im brauhaus bösen
die nicht so gut dann ist alles gut okay
weil das ist eine arbeit die macht sich
nicht jeder und hatte hier muss ich
jetzt gucken wer sich die verschiedenen
gattungen abdecke also ich muss
vielleicht gericht haben wir das muss
ein fischgericht haben wenn er
vegetarisch kochen vegetarischen gern
haben ich muss immer das essen auch wenn
ich sage ich muss sagen okay dann bin
ich gespannt was du aussuchen wirst ich
habe so viele fragen aber suchte erstmal
gerechter ist wenn ich normalerweise
testen gehe mit jemand anderem dann ist
es immer so dass der die gänge bestellen
muss die ich auch noch gerne probieren
würde also jetzt halt so wir haben die
vorspeisen hauptgänge des heers die sind
volle portion er so groß dass man nicht
nur drei gänge essen kann das eigentlich
fünf gängen umstellen da bin ich echt
platz war sie also mache ist ich
bestelle eingang und du musst ja
unternehmen und dann kann ich bei dir
probieren dadurch kann nicht einfach
eine größere anzahl an gerichten abdeckt
aber nur wenn jemand genauso fein raum
wie du hat oder als würdest du sonst
auch wenn du gehst ja wahrscheinlich
nicht mit mit privaten freunden oder
doch auch doch ja das ist total wichtig
weil die aufgabe anderen blick haben die
sagen die sagen ne zb das essen war gut
aber das habe ich nicht verstanden und
dann kriege ich ja noch einen anderen
blick verbraucht also ist das stehe auch
mit mit anderen restaurantkritiker
testen aber ich bringe viel mehr mit
leuten essen zu gehen die das vielleicht
noch nicht zu kennen ich bin ja auch
zwischenzeitig zum hobby restaurant
wenn ich vielleicht du bist perfekt was
man hat merkt die karte ist es gibt
keine klare linie
eine französische astronom mediterran
ich mag es grundsätzlich die bereits
sehr klare linie geben ich glaube dass
das für restaurants einfacher ich will
die leute aber wenn es um geld geht
dahin ich krieg französischen krieg
mediterran ja aber jesus so dass der
wiener lorenz einfach die sachen kocht
auf ge rainer sass burghart gut
andererseits so ein bisschen das best-of
für seine kunden und das ist das ist das
konzept des ganzen und da ich weiß dass
das so ist ist das wieder für mich auch
wenn ich nicht kennen würde würde ich
sagen ja ja
wir haben sogar gina und dann haben
sagen aber die gänseleber terrine die
super klassisch französische ist dann
haben wir gesagt mir gern mit mango
ananas nicht gesehen er im asiatischen
bereich also es gibt ja aber wie gesagt
das ist ja das konzept wenn es viel
funktioniert wunderbar schon bei sachen
gesehen ich bin fett essen muss ich
würde denken dass wir die ganze
batterien testen das stimmt ja solche
und dann sagt man sich die zivis aber
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher also ich
soll mal wieder aber wer weiß ja wie ich
finde ich gar nicht so schwer also auch
hier ist es wieder draußen gutes
grundprodukt aber eigentlich ist das
kochen dann nicht so ja was mich
interessiert ist dass mehr von unten
tomaten was ist wenn er wirklich für
baut da ist das vom anrichten hier ein
bisschen mehr arbeit und kann über
vegetarische arbeiten gerade deswegen
ist das so spannender gang meist
scheitern die köche wird spannend
vegetarischen gängen was auch noch
spannend ist und fertig gebacken
garnelen hätte ich sogar gedacht das ist
eher nichts für dich also gebacken die
so ein kleiner trick so friedberg
ihr merkt schon wie viel sorgfalt in die
auswahl der speisen fließt es ist
eigentlich im prinzip ganz einfach es
werden die schwierigsten speisen
genommen die muss man aber erstmal
identifizieren in unserem fall ist es
eine mail von bunten tomaten geworden
und eine gänseleber träne dazu zwei
offene rheine der tag an beginnt ich
habe mal zwei auslesen mitgebracht aber
von dünger von 2006 kleinen schätzen
chefs keller dann eröffnen karte von
clemens busch wie auslese von 2009/10
und das ist auch was ganz besonderes von
der musik das ist schmetterlingen das
ist ein kanadischer und amerikanischer
winter die sind und daher stellen
vielleicht um holz ausgebaut werden sie
auch gleich von der farbe sehen derzeit
nur die frage bei denen 2 so weit ist
absolute spitzen spitzenbetriebe dann
auch von den nahezu sechs trägt die abi
jahrgang gewesen clemens busch 2009 10
eine der absolute vorreiter des bio
weinbaus in deutschland druck was seinem
kasten und der soll man je für einen
nerd oktober eingeführt haben ich habe
wirklich 80 prozent überhaupt nicht
verstanden deshalb habe ich mich dazu
entschieden mich mehr auf das essen zu
konzentrieren weil das kann ich besser
beurteilt die sagen aber so viel die
weiteren wirklich wirklich lecker und
die kommen auch langsam rein in das
thema man merkt auf jeden fall die weine
haben die gerichte aufs neue level
gehoben und grundsätzlich gibt es bei
weinen auch viel zu bewerten deshalb ein
paar worte von carsten dazu ja das ist
echt mit bemerkenswerte beinkraft wir
auch ein sehr sehr gutes zeichen weil
wir haben einige anfangs tiefe also
viele restaurants haben nur junge jagen
und das bei vielen gängen braucht man
etwas gereift ist konnte er hat einige
legenden hier drin und ich gucke immer
nach einigen weingütern wo ich weiß wenn
die auf der karte stehen dann haben die
rechte an dann wissen wir was gerade
angesagt oder was sind die klassiker
unter cook mit den preis an wie hoch ist
die kalkulation da ist das fair oder ist
es im endeffekt er es gibt restaurants
und hinterher sagen nur eine flasche
steht weil ja auch kein mensch danke
danke die vorspeise ist das ist die
gänseleber terrine mit rosmarin branche
haben wir hier kräutersalat und apfel
zwiebel config das erste was ich sehe wo
ich mir denke jetzt nicht schon so die
kritiker darunter dass unter den salat
ja ja das ist nicht so gut ich habe
direkt getestet ist sie waren die war
noch da waren ja das ist auch total
wichtig vom anrichten her ist das jetzt
nicht so schön den salat kann man hat
auch wirklich ein bisschen bisschen
attraktiver anrichten
es ist jetzt klar wir sind ja nicht im
sternerestaurant sondern danach was ganz
ganz dicht dran deshalb setzt so da auch
dieses ausgewiesenen standard setzen ja
genau als ich würde jetzt nicht erwarten
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn sie es noch
schöner gemacht hätten ja aber es ist
kein problem das sie dass er sehr sehr
einfach am teller gelegt haben das kann
ich hier akzeptieren
[Musik]
hast du deine gedanken ich habe ja alles
einzeln probiert was für die terrine gut
gearbeitet und die hat wirklich den den
schmelz sie hatten deutlichen gänseleber
über geschmack prägnanter würze aber die
übertönt nicht in den geschmack der
ganze hass auch ernst machen und so
wollen wir die konsistenz von gut leicht
kühlt so muss sie serviert werden das
finde ich gelungen zwei klassiker werden
beherrscht dieses apfel zwiebel chutney
oder 10 4 was wir hier haben erinnert
mich fast ein rot ruhe
das weihnachtliches gehören damit der
ganze wagen total ich glaube dass
irgendwie konnte gewürz und her was drin
ist sind oder so was in die richtung
geht in der säure eher zurückhaltend
aber kann ich mir auch gut in der kombi
vorstellt was das tatsächlich sehr gut
zusammen ja zusammen gedacht dass einmal
eine gabel die beide nicht auf die reihe
kriege das ist ja nicht aber auch direkt
nacheinander probiert man dachte ich
okay das passt super zusammen das ist
total wohl das ganze das finde ich
spannend dass sie ein bisschen rosmarin
drin haben ende bringt das ist eher
ungewöhnlich ist auch er nicht so süß
und was kriegt man die deutlich besser
das ist also ein bisschen mehr in
richtung leichtigkeit gemacht worden das
finde ich die schöne variationen problem
mit dem salat die vinaigrette ist echt
sehr heftig wenn nicht er ist wirklich
sehr viel säure sehr viel essig das geht
für mich nicht so richtig zusammen ich
finds auch kürzlich von der tabelle her
sind große blätter hast du musst du
irgendwie damit du das irgendwie
zusammen aufbringen das ist nicht so 100
prozent durch das würde ich mir anders
mit den salat empfängt dessen
fremdkörper fast nur auf zwischen den
vielen tests musst du gucken dass wir
wieder auf null kommt irgendwas hat
irgendwie ja ja schon dass ich wieder
ein bisschen essen einlade im ganzen
schon immer wieder konzentrieren aber
ich finde solartechnik in schutz das ist
keine besonders pfiffige wenig gast kann
man echt anders machen das ist auch
jetzt als jemand der neben dem
restaurant kritiker sitzt und das ist
absolut losen wir alles also es ist wohl
nachvollziehbar sowie als max moritz für
die vereine erklärt habe fühle ich mich
jetzt gerade weil er seine art ist
das schlechte auf dem teller
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich alles
irgendwie erfrischend neu lecker und ein
gutes gericht aber das fehlt uns richtig
gut oder letztlich perfekt zugenommen da
können auch kicken machst du es so dass
du keine keine spuren hinterlässt das
muss der trainer immer auch gegessen
werden also ich es in meisten fällen
tatsächlich gucken will sind die mengen
so gemacht dass du als gast nach
herausgeht und bis vor gut gefüllt aber
nicht so besagt nämlich dass schwer
deswegen normalerweise esse ich meistens
fast alles auf aber wenn ich so salata
wo ich denke das macht mir jetzt gar
keinen spaß
dann muss er jetzt schon probieren und
dann geht's zum nächsten halt in bern
besuch von max bekommt von max lorenz
der uns mal wieder mit offenen armen
empfangen hat jetzt und ich fand es ganz
interessant aus direkt feedback gegeben
das machst du wahrscheinlich wenn du im
komitee unterwegs bist nicht mehr aber
wie nehmt ihr beide hier also die den
dialog also das zusammenspiel von koch
und restaurantkritiker gibt es kochs
köche die dich überhaupt nicht sein
können bei dem die straße wechseln würde
ist ja und mache ich gern eine reinhauen
die haben tatsächlich sehr offene
kommunikation also max hopp der auch
sagt ich hab neue gerichte kommt vorbei
probier die gib mir dein feedback und
das ist aber außergewöhnlich also es
gibt viele köche die wollen das gar
nicht hören
die super stolz es geht dann schnell für
kollegen sind die richtung
majestätsbeleidigung wie kannst du es
wagen das brot zu kritisieren das habe
ich heute morgen nach 18 stunden noch
gebacken wollte sie sagt es ist das lied
hat nachher einfach vom dialog und keine
ahnung ich sage mal im fußball wäre
menschen die so gut wenn es nicht
ronaldo geben aber naidoo werden so gut
für dass sich messe geben würde die
brauchen sich halt einfach die wii
spielen sich gegenseitig hoch aber ich
glaube maxx wolke wann kommt
ich würde ich möchte mich immer noch
fleisch kampagne trinken wird als aber
ich finde es richtig cool also diesen
einblick zu bekommen so dieses
zusammenspiel das ist auch durchaus
besonders wichtig dass das wir euch auch
mal meine am tisch haben ich weiß da
fragst die bzo niña danke tschüss da
geht man hintereinander weg erreicht wie
das x und hier ist es einfach neun
jahren und das ist halt natürlich auch
schön und sage ich mal ich glaube ich
glaube das wort freundschaft wäre
vermessen aber eine tiefe verbundenheit
zur kulinarik und den respekt eben
einzeln gekommen in diesen dimensionen
das video das wirklich
schon längst wegen des videos deutlich
länger als sonst aber das muss es sein
das darf ist wie ich freue mich auf
jeden fall auf den nächsten gang ein
bisschen schon 360 grad am ende ja ja ja
aber dass man das schreiben werde das
ist das ungewöhnlichste gericht gewesen
oft auf der karte mit brot und tomaten
sie haben diesen klassischen mit turm
gebaut weil es sieht schon so aus also
das boot sieht total krass aus ja ein
bisschen
zu essen ja und ich fange aber erstmal
trotzdem mit den beilagen hier angucken
wie gemacht sind
okay dass das bitte sie die haselnuss
pastor ist wirklich amtlich das ist sehr
sehr gut wenn die tatsächlichen
möglichkeiten
sehr gut abgeschmeckt das ist sehr auf
den punkt sehr präsent auch mal was ist
wenn man das sieht und basilikum fährst
du erwartest deutlich intensiver noch ja
du hast diese wahnsinnige frische
komponente auch dabei
das ist ob diesmal
ohne über den ladentisch
weshalb zu schneiden als wir machen bin
ich auch
schon hatte sieht relativ hell aus das
war jetzt so keine verstimmt über
geschmack ist natürlich sehr gut das ist
schade finde ist das pesto ist das so
aus und damit wird es eigentlich erst
richtig richtig gut aber du musst
basteln bis aus gericht wenn es sieht
gut aus wenn spence kommt wenn du so
einen tisch so wie es unlängst auch
gleich die augen auf aber für die
sinnhaftigkeit des essens wert besser
gewesen man hätte das pesto tatsächlich
vielleicht hinten drauf gestrichen wobei
dann zieht's eventuell ein dann kannst
du auch schon matschig werden aber ich
hetz und wie nähergebracht an den gang
ja ich bin geschmacklich den absatz von
der tea party ist das richtig richtig
lecker dass bode war wirklich gut ihr
habt eine schöne konsistenz das weiche
in der mitte ist gar nicht mal so zu
bemängeln also ich finde das ist
irgendwie auch schon fast ein schöner
kontrast und mir scheint richtig richtig
und carsten wie haben die vorspeisen
gegessen ja wir haben die beine zu den
vorspeisen getrunken kurz und bündig was
dann drucken eindruck ist der klassiker
gänseleber terrine sehr sehr gut gemacht
dollar beinahe zu geniale kommen die auf
jeden fall bestellen genau wissen er
absoluter tipp hier beim e von den
booten tomaten fand ich auch keine guten
tomaten jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen das ist super
geile story das war echt ziemlich gut
gelungen auch auf das sauerteigbrot auch
sehr gut kommt vom geschmack her auch
schön dünn geschnitten die tabelle die
leider nicht so gut nach kürzester zeit
sieht nicht mehr ganz so attraktiv aus
und man kriegt eigentlich wenig perfekte
gabel aber die einzelkomponenten die
personale ich glaube da muss man da
rangehen gucken wie kann man seinen gast
bringen und der wahl 1 bis 10 für die
forschung bei
1 bis 10 für die vorspeise liebe terrine
fand ich ja sehr gute mutter salat war
nicht so gut also wer das match 8 bis 9
wie für und würde ich untergehen wenn
ich nur für das beste was geben würde
würde sagen er absolut im gesamten ist
es für mich erst ja vielleicht
vielleicht
ja also ich merke schon ich hätte
wahrscheinlich wenn ich hier einfach nur
zum testen her gekommen wäre ohne cast
an meiner seite ich habe schon auf jeden
fall noch mal deutlich weniger anspruch
ich hätte wahrscheinlich denn zählten
mindestens der note besser bewertet ich
fand alles sehr sehr lecker aber das ist
eben die erfahrung auch wenn du hast ja
du hast den vergleich beweist wie es
absolut perfekt ist und das ist ja auch
genau das was du kannst was du machst
also deshalb finde ich es total
interessant und bin gespannt was du zu
unseren hauptgängen sagen würde ich muss
wirklich sagen auch ein paar tage später
bin ich immer noch begeistert mit
welcher akribie und mit wie viel
verständnis man essen behandeln kann und
irgendwo kann ich mir auch richtig gut
vorstellen weil auch ich selbst verstehe
es schon viel besser als noch vor
eineinhalb jahren mit dieser gesamten
reise hier auf youtube und karten
einfach so viel erfahrungen und von so
einem meister zu lernen ist wirklich
cool deshalb haben wir natürlich auch
die weiteren gängen mit der gleichen
aufmerksamkeit behandelt und wie das
aussah seht ihr jetzt damit es nicht zu
viel wird weil zwei vorspeisen waren
schon mächtig heime das ganze jetzt ein
bisschen ich habe mir einen kleinen
räuber teller genau das hat mir was
fertig gemacht bin gespannt sein ist
schon die ersten eindrücke ja genau ich
habe erst mal schon mal die die soße
probiert und die ist wie erwartet sehr
gut nach lienz wieder ganz klassisches
handwerk wir haben ganz ganz deutlich
eine oma note große not die ist einfach
zu erwerben punkten das ist das ist
jetzt in einem restaurant das
preisrichter angesiedelt ist wo das 1er
angesiedelt ist eine ungewöhnlich gute
qualität ja also das spürst du dass es
eben eine sterneküche ist die das ganze
mit marco eben über die preise
gesprochen hatten man sieht wie viel
also das muss man sagen dass und absolut
fair gepreist ist was ein bisschen da
bin ich aber unser super kritisch dazu
sagte schwierig
lachs ist ich habe dann lieber noch glas
aber man sieht er ist schon saftig ist
jetzt nicht so als wäre er trocken ja
also das ist das ist das so muss man
servieren wir viele leute wenn der basis
ist das nicht so umgehen wer also
deswegen er musste ihn zu machen im
sternerestaurant würde ich sagen das
gibt ab zu punkt ja da erwarte ich dass
es noch gar sieger ist hier ist es genau
der punkt der inhalt der treffen muss
tatsächlich das einzige ist ein bisschen
schade ist es durch die stadt musste sie
schmeckt fast ein bisschen spinat und
ganzen also wenig bin ich kräuter
aufspielen
und hat die kruste dann hätte man eben
in kranj element dabei was wäre schön
allein sind gut ist gesorgt und so eine
gute kosten der soße zu kriegen das ist
schon das ist schon bemerkenswert ist
gemüse es auf den punkt als ganz ganz
viele pluspunkte hier leben kleiner
minuspunkt
zwei hauptspeisen das ist mal wieder ein
ganz klassischer freitag 14 50 wir sind
beim vierten gericht an gekommen bei dem
sechs und zwei
leben eigentlich womit beginnt für
mitarbeiter herzlich mit der russen
polen sehr cremig vereine rosmarin das
ist super start
wirklich gut so soll die sagen jetzt mal
die zutaten die die probleme tatsächlich
richtig länger bräuchte ich nichts
anderes
das ist das bauwerk samt der soße jetzt
einfach sehr schön falsch geschmack
wirkliche tiefe wirkliches noten ich bin
das ist meist das ganz klar bezeichnet
wird ordentlich gearbeitet
dennoch wenn ihr so sehr dass so zeigt
jetzt wie soll ich mich magst aber das
ist dann sterneköche anspruch noch roter
aber das ist wenn man es ist merkt man
es ist so zart was hat man wirklich
feinen geschmack dabei und das ist so
wie man es hier sehr werden sollte das
problem ist ansonsten wenn du gestern
dass die sich nicht auskennen die werden
mit sachen die noch roma sind nicht
glücklich werden
das stimmte für die
findung sein wird auch erwartet dass das
in dem cups würde noch irgendwas zu
ändern ja scheinbar ist aber nur gemeint
dass es in dem mantel ist guck ich
nochmal nach aber dann wäre es ja eher
die filter speck genau da wäre gefüllter
speck macht eigentlich ist es nur kapsel
im speckmantel gefüllt ist es nicht das
stimmt was wir jetzt auch eine sache die
wir werden würde ja ich hatte gedacht er
ist es noch mal eine farce oder so was
kann man verändern
das ist für mich so bisher das krasseste
also es schmeckt so wahnsinnig intensiv
also das symbol das habe ich noch nicht
woanders gegessen so und allein dafür
würde ich sofort wieder her absolut mehr
ist es eine große portion auch dass wir
werden eben die preise gesprochen hatte
hier 44 stücke davon und auch die
einzelkomponenten sind alle einfach
wirklich wirklich gut gearbeitet und
zusammen ist es so groß wurde für würze
reinlegen darüber geben uns gewundert
weil gefüllt auf der karte steht
in der ganzen sache die füllung ist das
filet und der speckmantel darum ist
quasi die höhle vom chef so gewollt ein
bisschen konversation mit den geldern zu
erhalten
das würde ich tatsächlich
ein wenn du schreibst dann gibt's
erwartungshaltung die muss ja für
ich würde nicht riskieren dass die gäste
dann sagen wo ich was schreibt mir da
drauf
das soll und wird sein das ist eine
blöde ausrede sein aber ich kann mir bei
max und nicht vorstellen dass ich
tatsächlich als direktor bei keinem
anderen corp
also für mich ist das eine glatte zehn
von zehn mit sternchen ich kann das
wirklich so lecker und ich bin gespannt
auf deine bewertung zu den beiden
hauptgängen die bewertung für den
hauptgang zuerst hatten wir das
lachsfilet unter der kräuterkruste mit
erbsen risotto bund möhren und hunger
schaum soße die homo schon so so fand
ich großartig richtig intensiv
toller krustentiere geschmack bunten gut
gegart absolutes otto war für mich das
highlight auf dem teller sie sagen super
schöne bis die kombination mit erbsen
quartal wahnsinnig stolz sich die
einzigen minuspunkte gibt es natürlich
für die kräuterkruste also einerseits
war sie nicht groß ohne große muss eben
die muss trick sein wenn es selbst also
ein bisschen es und sie war auch
geschmacklich sehr eindimensional das
ginge so eine spielart richtung die hat
einfach nicht gekickt also kräuter
müssen einfach noch nicht die schon
geben lachsfilet für mich eben diesen
ein ticken zu weg zu weit gegangen ich
habe es lieber noch glaser persönliche
vorlieben deswegen bin ich da nur bei
acht bis neun punkten das gefüllte
krebsfälle im speckmantel heute
höchstens und abzugs punkt ging für den
nach hatte das ist kein gefüllt das
kalbsfilet aber rein geschmacklich 10
das war es war alles auf den punkt das
war super lecker intel tatsächlich
komplett leer gegessen weil ich wollte
davon nichts übrig lassen da hat alles
alles gestimmt absoluter gang zum zum
glücklichen ich ja alles was karten weil
ich ein haken dran welche eins zu eins
ich würde aber ich würde mich definitiv
auf einen neuen entscheiden bei dem das
war supergut wenn ihr aber hierher kommt
bitte ist das kalbsfilet das ist so
lecker ist sowieso gut bisher bin ich
wirklich happy kulinarisch und jetzt
kommen noch das ist ja oder bisher haben
die echt sehr gut abgeliefert finde ich
dazu muss man sagen transparenz zusatz
vorher nie bescheid dass du bekommst wir
haben natürlich bescheid gesagt weil wir
hier drehen sollte man mal erwähnt habe
aber ich war schon oft hier die kochen
auch tatsächlich dann nicht anders ja
sogar das erste des heers da auch hier
gibt es natürlich wieder zwei mitteilen
aber auch wieder weil langsam füllt sich
dabei auf sie ein bisschen wir haben ja
eine schoko armen ritter mit zitrus obst
salaten und sieben ganz viele
verschiedene farben jetzt ein bisschen
rave und vielleicht dann lud orange
zitrone mandarine werden wir noch
genauer sehen und haselnuss weiß genau
was sagst du zur kombination von ich
neugierig gemacht hat mich neugierig
gemacht tatsächlich also diese daher
dass den schoko an bord verschwand und
dazu wirklich ein citrus salat also
wirklich sehr auf die säure zu gehen ist
mutig und dann aber wieder rasen das
alles was er tatsächlich zudem zu der
schoko note passt ja ich bin sehr
interessiert wie dass es tatsächlich zu
sagen geht das ist jetzt kein plating
was und herzlich
damit gibt es alles super schön aussieht
sondern es geht darum das ist lecker
aussieht dass die hauptkomponenten
präsentiert werden in meisten fällen ist
es so dass es das ist von der tabelle
her sinnvoller ist der einzige gang wo
sind jetzt ein bisschen aus zuvor waren
das war das mit dem mit dem ev ja das
war das außergewöhnliche das hat aber
auch nicht funktioniert ich finde für
das restaurant muss es gar nicht so
schwer weil das baute barrieren auf soll
einfach schön anrichten und so dass man
gut essen kann und das machen wir
schön fluffig
die schoko note ist nichts
das positiv finde ich dass sie dass der
zucker im unteren bereich ist gerade bei
schubert ist jetzt passiert wie das mit
zucker um sich geschleudert wird er nur
noch süßer du hast den leichten schock
für so einen schönen haselnuss geschmack
auch dass es nicht zu süß geworden und
deswegen funktioniert zwar ein bisschen
zitrusfrüchten ja wenn man jetzt so viel
zu viel süßes würde ich total raus
fallen aber jetzt ist wo die geben in
schönen leichten frisch und es geht viel
harmonischer zusammen als ich das
erwartet hatte das große finale das
letzte bisher ich bin so traurig wie
froh darüber also ich könnte nicht noch
viel länger essen aber es macht auch
wahnsinnig viel spaß was sagst du dazu
erstmal erstmal ist auffällig dass es
doch eine größere portion ist also wir
denken noch ein kleines crème brulée
dann danke
von der vom abgefilmten her sieht schon
karamellisiert aus was man gleich gucken
wie vidic geschichte sowie knusprig ist
der saison kommt finde ich attraktiv ist
es tatsächlich schön also ich find's
schön angerichtet auch das sich aus ein
schwarzes geschirr genommen haben das
passt sehr gut dazu weiß ist wieder
findet in dem schwarzem sesam das
poppige fußbäder bin ich sehr gespannt
weil ich nicht genau weiß was er gleich
das vorherrschen aroma sein wird ja also
rein optisch ist das geht das schon mal
absolut kenne ich auch cool und ich mag
auch dass sie so ein bisschen zu läuft
die form bei der durch hast du oben noch
mehr oberfläche für knusprige scareware
also bin ich gut nicht zu dick das
passiert ja häufig dann sieht man hier
schön dass man wirklich das mit bor
wandel gearbeitet worden ist soll die
schwarzen punkte sieht hat sich auch
nicht alles am boden gesammelt das gibt
es immer mal wieder an der vw schmeckt
für dich wie gut multivitaminsaft
totale erinnerung sesam quatsch der
schließt direkt an also ich ja auch
karamellisiert auch zuckerhaltig aber so
diesen kontrast schafft eigentlich
außerdem bin ich ja was war wirklich
eine frische note dabei der quandts
doppelt eigentlich nochmal die
karamellisierte noten wie wir haben wenn
ich auch ein element verzichten könnte
wäre am ehesten kommt aber der ist auch
optisch sehr schön aber die in
kombination mit diesem job ag sowie der
crème brulée die gerechte sehr gut auf
was für ein video ich sitze jetzt mit
carsten und max lorenz und ich bin
wunderbar gesättigt und wieder angeheizt
hat es macht immer wieder spaß hier an
diesem tisch zu sitzen sagt danke das
nun schon zum zweiten mal empfängst hier
was ist dein fazit du kannst es jetzt
direkt vor den ohren und augen von max
sagen genug eindruck
ich hab schon gemerkt so gegen ändere
auch das interesse auf jeden fall da
warten wir auf jeden fall publikum hier
ja wir hatten also dieses relativ klein
was ein fahrzeug das das was du heute
denke ich vor allen dingen hauptgang da
ist und das ist nämlich das diesem thema
hier ist super klassisch gehalten also
champagner sorbet französische
käseauswahl und dann hat man noch die
kripo eben auch super klassisch schöne
variationen mit dem titelsong b also das
ist wirklich auch ungewöhnlich dass man
sind der kombination hat hat auch sehr
gut funktioniert er krank war der crème
brulée war gut drin note war gut die
cremigkeit war gut was nicht gebraucht
hat er den sandplatz wobei der auch also
der hat eine wirkung das schön lustig
aber wer weiß etwas zu viel zucker habe
ich dich das bisschen zu schwer für mich
aber sieht schön aus aber schokolade
narita auch wieder eine kleine variation
der romand sie wollen eigentlich sehr
klassisch bleiben niemanden überfordern
aber eben doch ein bisschen was bringen
was neu ist gut funktioniert nicht zu
viel zucker haselnüssen ebenso schöne
radroute nicht so wie zucker und
überraschenderweise der zitrusfrucht
salat
[Gelächter]
das hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert ich
werde ich nicht gedacht das ist dass es
geht aber da der zucker so runter
gefahren war der citrus richtig schön
kicken können und also beides schöne
gericht ich würde sagen kripo je
acht von mir beim warmspielen amavita
ebenfalls da hat ja also ich weiß gar
nicht was wahr und was mache ich hier
eigentlich das ist doch ein profi sitzt
neben mir und erklärt was sonst kann
sich keiner ist hinzufügen also absolut
interessant total aufschlussreich dass
heute alles mit zu leben das essen war
super lecker also ich hab gehört acht
von zehn
entfiel ich bitte dich ja so aus graphen
und das hat ja nochmal was ist es ja was
besonderes ich sitze da durchsetzt so 22
kölner kollegin und ich mache meine
youtube-videos also danke dass ihr mich
dass er mich auf nehmt ihr solltet auch
mal bei max vorreiter und danke nochmal
an euch beide und das ist ein besonderes
video was jetzt zu ende geht bis zum
nächsten fahrzeug mit anschauen